عنوان للفشل السياسي اكثر وصف ممكن يختصر
حال جلسات البرلمان اللبناني لانتخاب رئيس
البلد بعد انتهاء عهد ميشيل عون اللي
كانوا تيار البرتقالي بيسموه العهد القوي
نفس العهد اللي شهد كوارث ما مر فيها بلد
في العصر الحديث من انفجار المرفا المخيف
واللي الى اليوم ما طبعا لازم نذكر انه ما
تحاسب فيه ولا شخص الى اكبر انهيار
اقتصادي للبلد وما ننسى طبعا سيطره
ميليشيا حزب الله التابعه لايران على قرار
عون وسهره باسيل العهد القوي اللي انتشرت
في نهايته ظاهره اقتحام الناس للبنوك بس
علشان ياخذوا جزء من اموالهم المحتجزه ومع
كل هذه الماسيسي بين عقد البرلمان مره ولا
مره لانتخاب رئيس لكن لا صوتي حلو فوق صوت
المسخره بحسب ما قال احد انه في جلسه
اليوم اللي فشل فيها البرلمان
مر الخامسه لانتخاب رئيس وكانت غلبه
للورقه البيضاء اللي انتخبوها غضب النواب
معظم النواب انتخبوها كرئيس لبلاد العجائب
التليفزيونات ويا اللي ناطر انه ننتخب
رئيس من بعد تقريبا 10 ايام شهور عم بيسال
اذا هذه الجلسات هي جلسات عفوا راح استعمل
كلام اللي عم بيستعملوها بره اذا هذه
الجلسه الجلسات مسخره او ضحك تقول او فقط
[موسيقى]
مع دوله الرئيس رئيس مجلس النواب بس اذا
في قتلنا على اي ماده عم تستمر سوريا لا
انا قراته كثير منيح انا اريدته كثير منيح
على اي ميدي عم تستند تشرف في عندي بحكي
انا وياك ابراهيم
ينضم الينا من بيروت الناشط السياسي
فاروقي يعقوب اهلا فيك معانا يا فاروق
يعني الحقيقه كل ما بحضر جلسه من الجلسات
او نقاش ومن النقاشات بانبهر اكثر واكثر
هذا ايضا واحد من النقاشات المبهره كيف
شفتوا انت
يعني
ذكرني اللي عم يصيب البرلمان بمشهد للممثل
الراحل حسن حسني
بيقولوا في يا فاشل يا فاشل يعني هذا
النموذج من الفشل المريع
لايداء السلطه اللبنانيه وكيف
بتدير هذا البلد يعني شو اليه كيف بندار
هذا البلد اليوم عم بيصير هو مسخره موصوف
يعني هي مسخره منظمه مسخره مسخره عارفين
شو عم يعملوا يعني هالقد هالقد البلد تم
تم فراغ من مضمون السياسي اليوم هذا البلد
اللي جايب له مثل لما بتشتري التليفزيون
عم يلعبوا وكل واحد جايب كل واحد زعيم
عصابه مجمع اولاد حواليه مجموعه من النواب
هو زعيم وهو بينتخبوا لروحي هو بقرر مين
بينجح مين ما بينجح وبجيبه معه على
البرلمان وبيقرروا شو بدهم في ثلاث اربع
خمس يعني خمس ست اذا بدي رؤوس
المجموعه
في الدستور نفسه انت بدك تقوله الا في
اللي جالسين بينفذوا الدستور اللي هم
فاهمين الدموع
المشكله انه هم مش عم يطبقوا الدستور
وفاتحين على فاتحين على حسابهم يعني على
طريقه
الجلسات همم مسخره مخيفه يعني مسخره
ما كان في اجابه
ليش هو ليش رئيس مجلس النواب يخبرنا على
اي انونه اي بنسكر مجلس النواب سنتين
بالمفتاح ممنوع حدا يفوت عليه
لحام هذا البلد حزب الله في في فتيح
لمكاتب لاداره هذا البلد كل واحد معه
مفتاح كل معه مشان معهم مفتاح ما بيمري
معه مفتاح همم رئاسه الحكومه لانه مع
السنه مش متحال فيهم المفتاح يعني اليوم
بيعطوا لهذا اليوم
يعني النبي ان شاء الله يعني ما بقى رجع
عالبيت
[ضحك]
على بيته يعني
يمكن لانه بما انه يعني صهروا كمان وكل
شيء
اول شيء نحن ما خصناها يعني احنا مره ضفنا
نحنا نحنا جمهور نحنا محكومين مثلنا مثل
غير نحنا من ايهم هذا البلد عم نقاوم
بحقنا الديمقراطيه عن ايه من ايهم لحتى
يكون في بلد ويكون في دولي ويكون في
مؤسسات هذا اللي عمل هذه المقاومه اللي
احنا بنعملها هذه المقاومه المدنيه
الديمقراطيه احنا هاي ما قومتنا نحن ما
فينا غير منويجه هذه المنظومه هذه السلطه
انتم ما بتتخيلوا مدى الفشل اللي بالبلد
فشل المامون يا جماعه فشل بالبلد ما في
كهرباء ما في ماء ما في طب احد ادنى من اي
شيء كدولي راعي مختفي مختفي فاليوم ايدول
النواب مني لازم يستحوا
يعني لازم يخجلوا من حاله لانه فعلا
بيمثلوا يعني بيمثلوا اسوا نموذج اداره
الحكم نموذج
مطلوبين للعداله متهمين مطلوبين للتحقيق
في نواب مطلوبين عقوبات دوليه يعني على
طريقه بابلو اسكوبار يعني طريقه طريقه
اداره بابلو اسكوبار يعني حسي حالك فانت
مش فايده مجلس النوايا بتحسي حالك يعني
فقتي شيء مخيف في بني سويف في
124 واحد 122 واحد نص المطلوبين الانتربول
يعني في عن جد في مشكله في ازمه
تشريع شو المعايير اللي تم التشريع عليها
البلد ما احنا بنعرف
احنا على قد ما نعلق لانه هالقد الوضع
هالقد الوضع فعلا مضحك يعني
انت اليوم طرحت اسئله كثيره ايش هي
المعايير والطرح سؤال كمان ثاني مهم انه
فين المفاتيح راح اختفت المفاتيح على
العموم يعني لما تقدر
شو المشكله
ما منتبهين البلد وين رايح يعني بعد بعد
الرعوني شغاله بعدهم يوزعوا الحصص بعضهم
بتاصموا ما تغير شي نور
مال نموذج الوزاره
والنواب يعني
للاسف يعني اللي بيصير نحن بنشكرك على هذه
المداخله كانت معنا او كان معنا من لبنان
[موسيقى]